cela fait une semaine que les forces
russes se sont retirés de Carson et
tandis que la ville se réjouit encore de
sa liberté retrouvée d'autres commencent
à prendre la mesure de l'ampleur des
crimes de guerre commis par les troupes
russes durant l'occupation le médiateur
ukrainien des droits de l'homme a
déclaré à France 24 que dans tous les
territoires occupés les agressions
envers la population était systématiques
et méthodique
il y a des centaines de nos soldats que
la Russie a torturé et tué contre la
convention de jeunesse ils ont préparé
un système pour terroriser et tuer les
Ukrainiens
il y a quoi je suis trop mignon je veux
que le monde comprenne
que ce que la Russie a fait sur le
territoire ukrainien
est un génocide des jurés du peuple
ukrainien
quand il tue des femmes et des enfants
quand ils bombardent et tire sur des
civils
cela devrait être porté devant la Cour
mondiale l'humanitaire
la police et les enquêteurs ukrainiens
ont trouvé dans la région de Kerson des
dizaines de corps montrant des signes de
torture tandis que la population nous a
parlé de la terreur que se met les
troupes russes qui kidnappaient des
civils de façon aléatoire ou bien qui
arrêtait toute personne montrant des
signes de soutien à l'Ukraine les
procureurs ukrainiens ont ouvert des
enquêtes sur plus de 40 cas de ce qu'il
considère être décrivent de guerre voilà
pour la situation sur